you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer I'm going to try three
puzzles and in this first one it's white
to move and I'm just gonna share my
thoughts along the way so this is a
weird one seems pretty constructed
unless White's whole army got wiped out
in an actual game but I highly doubt
that
so okay what's the big trick here mm all
right so who are the three at which
three attacking pieces this is my first
thought which three attacking pieces are
going to do the trick I don't see how
this bishop it would be able to
contribute eventually you could force
the King to f8 with the bishop moving
and then like a rook check King takes
Queen check on h5 h7 eventually if you
wanted to as why you could force the
King to f8
if Bishop a3 there's always some Knight
block and that negates the bishops
influence on the dark squares and would
he really come about on this diagonal
what do you really do anything on this
diagonal I'm not so sure about that
so my first rough thought is that it's
going to be up to the Queen rook and
light square bishop to do something
maybe this pawn could somehow do some
damage alright let's let's consider here
another quick thought I had was after
the bishop moves maybe you could take
this Knight yeah actually you know what
another thing first second I was just
ready to say Bishop takes Knight at some
point there's always a recapture and
you'd be in check even if that wasn't
the case here's another move that black
would have in response to this check
it's not just the knight it's just the
pawn upon that could move so okay where
should the Bishop move this is my first
real thought as to what the first move
should be so Bishop moves somewhere
hmm if I were a bishop where would I
want to move here bishop g6 I guess to
put some pressure on f7 Bishop g6 gang
GA I really don't see where it would be
going after rook AJ King h8 Queen h5
King g8 Queen h7 King f8 Queen h8 King
eise Evan what's the follow-up
I'm having trouble seeing what the
follow-up would be there okay what about
aha
what about Queen here first switching
the move order let's not let this King
be so fast to running to f8 so I think
the first move is Queen to h5 as
appealing as this discovered check is
it's unavoidable still after Queen h5 is
the first move and then we're
threatening Queen to h8 mate I think
that's it not a bishop move but first a
Queen move and then a bishop move
probably wherever yeah that's got to be
a lizard I think Queen h5 all right and
now okay what's the plan here oh hang on
I think we still have to be quite
accurate for if Bishop moves now King g8
I know that what am i doing it's it's
made Queen h8 it's ready what I was
ready to do just there was play Queen to
f7 this thread is still there and it's
good that's game over all right so that
that came down to what my initial
thought was immediately discovered check
but the king is just too quick to get
over to this safe haven on e7 so just
switching the move order first Queen h5
and then the bishop move okay got it
let's try puzzle 2 of 3 black to move
hmm this is uh this is it seems like a
position that you would see out of the
Arroyo Lopez okay let's see what should
black do candidate moves alright well
let's see what's any checking moves
there's no checking moves
okay what about attacking the Queen in
some way do that she's up
detected and what more you'll have to
realize that before I started out
recording this video there wasn't a dog
barking but he's relentless that dog I
tell you that dog knows that beagle that
beagle definitely knows when I try to do
a video it's been over a week and yeah
you know he's he's off and running here
okay so what should we have here I'm not
sure
where is where is white vulnerable I'm
not really seeing it like night at 4:00
so what you're attacking a queen just
gets taken
what's this Bishop going to do that's
great
no wow
all right no it might just be pawn takes
I made it sound so simple by using that
word just it might just be this that
can't be right pawn takes Bishop takes
Knight there might be something to it
if pawn takes pawn and Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes pawn with then Queen
takes pawn on c3 hitting the bishop and
then forcing through maybe the promotion
of the pond but there's alternatives
that Y would have after pawn takes pawn
and rook takes I I feel like there
should be something other than this hmm
alright this one is clearly stumping me
see I'm not I'm not recognizing right
here where White is vulnerable I'm still
trying to understand this position more
much more clearly this is a forcing move
I mean because it is it is throwing a
punch at something it's giving white
some direction not sure how else you're
supposed to be forceful in this position
b4 it seems kind of slow
I somehow think it is this capture oh I
think it might be if pon takes rook
takes then there's night see one
is it I think that's it that's got to be
it I'm not seeing any more aggressive
move let's just go with that
it's correct and now I'm down to pond
takes or queen takes it's probably it's
probably pond takes first
yeah if Queen takes first
the rook could play here take the pawn
and indirectly defend the bishop so I
think it's pond takes first yes and then
I believe you actually take on c3
if rook takes then you promote with the
Queen actually not so fast
one moment here because if Queen takes
pawn rook takes promotion to a queen now
allows Knight be one blocking the check
and defending the rook on c3
so I think you should promote first rook
takes and then Queen takes pawn
attacking the rook and then getting that
piece back here
thank you promote first that is correct
and then take here with the double
attack on the bishop and rook and that's
it that's the solution of that one so
you're not really winning so much
material with that variation are you
you're winning two pawns I guess that's
convincing enough at the end of all this
what do you end up with two connected
past pawns
okay let's try I'm not really a big fan
of that puzzle let's see if this last
one is gonna be anything exciting I feel
like I've seen this one before okay hmm
all right well there's some intersection
squares that are immediately coming to
mind right here f6 is one of them where
two or more white pieces can move -
those tend to be appealing squares where
where we can smash through oh let's see
this bishops pinned it's one thing to
know many checking modes rook takes
Queen takes bishop probably not Queen
here I'm not sure what that's even
accomplishing
all righty would there be something like
rook takes here and then rook takes here
not so sure about that
whoo you know what it might be oh I
think I might see what it is I think you
might actually capture on this square
twice at the end of it the King has to
recapture on f6 then there's rook f5
followed by made on e4 or f5 depending
on where the King goes I think that's it
smash through on f6 just a quick
variation Bishop takes f6 pawn takes
rook takes King takes is the only move
rook f5 if then King e6 Queen f5 is mate
if King V five then Queen B four would
be main I'm wondering however about this
first move why am I so locked in to
Bishop takes as the first move
maybe because if rook takes first it's
with check pon takes and now if Bishop
takes it's not as forcing which would
allow rook g8 to defend the bishop if
Luke takes pawn takes Bishop takes
there's a defense against the bishop on
g7 with rook and g8 I think after Bishop
takes pawn there's two very forcing
moves a just to take the bishop with the
Queen and B just to move the bishop from
f6 to deliver discovered check so I
think this is this was my only concern
which piece to take with first on f6 and
I'm pretty sure it's the bishop that is
it and now with the rook that is correct
and now rook check here I didn't even
consider this move for the King but it
would run into h4 mate rook f4 and
that's as far as it goes like I was
saying King here Queen efore I was
mistaken for a second I was saying after
King e6 Queen here would be mate
close but it's not me right away if King
here you give check and then made on f7
eventually you're gonna give mate
somehow King e7 you take the bishop and
then play to f6 and that'll do it okay I
wasn't really a big fan of these three
puzzles but I guess I'm okay with still
getting all three feel free to share how
you did in the comment section below and
I'll catch you in the next video take
care bye
you